Once Upon a Time Sony was one of the
largest electronics companies in the
world they were synonymous with home
entertainment high quality cameras and
hit movies but the past 20 years haven't
been so kind to Sony as it's simply been
loss after loss after loss take their TV
business for example up until 2006 Sony
was the world's number one TV
manufacturer a title that they had held
for decades but since then it's been the
Samsung show in fact Samsung has now
held this title for 17 years themselves
Sony didn't just lose their dominant
position either they straight up got
sidelined in fact Sony currently stands
at fifth place within the TV Market
beaten by Samsung Vio LG and TCL with
only 6% market share things were going
so bad that Sony actually decided to
spin off their TV business after 10
years worth of losses but it's not just
their legacy businesses in which Sony
has been getting burned either they've
had quite a bit of trouble entering new
Industries as well such as the computer
industry after failing to break into the
PC industry for years Sony ended up
selling off their PC business a similar
story can be seen with their smartphone
efforts as well they haven't yet quit
making smartphones but for several years
now they haven't even been able to break
1% market share globally to be honest
the only Sony segment that's still super
strong is selling PlayStations
everything else is at best stagnating or
slowly bleeding market share seeing all
this I don't think you'd be surprised to
hear that Sony was losing tens of
billions of dollars during the worst of
it but despite all of this Sony has
somehow been turning this entire
situation around after several years of
losses Sony has been posting consistent
profits for 6 years now their stock
graph tells the same story after their
peak in 2000 Sony fell over 90% over the
next 12 years but since then they've
recovered much of these losses but how
could this be possible Sony has been
losing ground in basically every segment
that we know them for well join me as we
take a look back at Sony's existential
crisis and how they were able to come
out on the other side
profitable Sony's Fall From Grace shows
how even major corporations can falter
if they don't adapt to Changing Times
with high inflation and historically
High interest rates were're very much
experiencing a shift in the investing
landscape just a few weeks ago the
Federal Reserve opted to pause rates
leaving us with a historically High
interest rate of
5.25% investing in bonds now means
locking in high rates before the Federal
Reserve starts decreasing them once
again companies and legendary investors
are well aware of of this and that's why
they've been investing hundreds of
billions of dollars into bonds over the
past year if you'd like to leverage
these high interest trades for yourself
that's where Silo our upcoming Bond
investing platform comes into play with
Silo you can not only invest in
treasuries but you can also invest in
bonds issued by corporations such as
Apple Nike or Coca-Cola all with no
markups and $500,000 in sipc insurance
and $2.5 million in FDIC insurance if if
that sounds worthwhile please consider
checking out Silo in the description
below but anyways taking a look back the
story of Sony's Fall From Grace can be
attributed to a lot of factors but
likely one of the most consistent
factors is repeatedly missing the boat
with new technology for example let's
take a look back to October 23rd 2001
right after the Doom Bubble Burst most
tech companies were reeling from their
Doom losses and struggling to secure
funding and improve employee morale but
but there was one notable exception
Apple had already gone through their own
exponential crisis in the mid99s and
they were just now starting to turn
things around and October 23rd 2001 was
the fateful day that they would announce
the iPod in retrospect this doesn't seem
like a big deal especially in comparison
to the iPhone but this was actually a
massive blow for Sony you see ever since
the Walkman launched in 1979 Sony became
synonymous with portable audio just to
give you a sense of how successful the
Walkman was Sony was able to sell over
400 million units but with a single
presentation Apple would throw two
decades of President out the window and
establish themselves as the modern music
player fast forward for years to March
11th 2005 and Sony would find themselves
in a very similar situation Samsung
would announce the world's largest LCD
TV coming in at 82 in this TV was
completely out of reach for the average
person but that didn't matter this TV
wasn't designed to sell a bunch of units
or even push forward technology it was
designed to make people think that
Samsung was pushing forward technology
it established an association between
Samsung and Innovation and this was just
the first of many Samsung theatrics
after this you would have 3D TVs curved
TVs OLED QED mini LED nanoled and
whatever else they decide to slap before
led to be honest most consumers have no
clue what any of these terms actually
mean but that doesn't matter all that
matters is that people associate all of
these new fancy terms with Samsung and
LG not Sony and that's not a coincidence
that's by Design basically the same
thing played out within the digital
camera space as well up until the 2000s
Kodak was an Untouchable Behemoth they
controlled over 80% of of the US market
and about half of the global market not
to mention they were the fifth most
valuable brand in the entire world but
despite this they would eventually drop
the ball with digital cameras making way
for new competitors to rise up this
would have been the perfect time for
Sony to Brand themselves as the leader
of digital cameras but instead Canon
would take on this image and become the
new dominant player none of this is to
say that Sony was truly behind in any of
these markets whether it's MP3 players
TVs or cameras in fact they would
usually launch similar products in
parallel with the market leaders and if
you ask anyone who actually bought Sony
products they would have nothing but
good things to say about Sony in fact
even many experts would say that Sony
products are more reliable and higher
quality than the so-called Market
leaders to this day but none of this
matters because the reality was that
their competitors destroyed them when it
came to brand and Market positioning and
it wasn't just one or two segments it
was across the board but this only tells
half the story as not all of Sony's
decline can be explained Away by just
strong
competition the reality is that much of
Sony's demise is actually their own
fault you see Sony was very much bloated
heading into the 2000s they had just
come off an incredible run throughout
the 80s and '90s which led them
expanding into every industry you can
think of Sony had a bank they had an
insurance division they were making
anime they were pushing out James Bond
movies they were all over the place the
reason that Sony was so successful in
the first place was because they were
able to produce extremely reliable and
affordable consumer electronics but as
they expanded into every sector Under
the Sun not only did they start to lose
this identity but they're spending more
and more time just managing all of these
businesses as opposed to actually
running and improving them it was the
classic Pitfall of a bloated company
with nearly 200,000 employees but
luckily the best evidence that Sony had
lost their way was their executive team
for some reason whenever companies get
really big they decide to hire random
Outsiders as CEOs as opposed to someone
who's been there and knows the company
in and out Intel has done this ge has
done this Nokia has done this and Sony
would do this as well in the late 9s
Sony would hire a lifelong media
executive named Howard Stringer to be
the president of US operations I've got
nothing personal against Howard but
seriously this guy didn't have an
engineering background had no experience
running an electronics company and had
little grasp of what made Sony
successful in the first place but for
whatever reason Sony would decide to
promote Howard to CEO and the chairman
of Sony in 2005 also I should say he
couldn't even speak Japanese which you
would think is quite important for a
Japanese company with a majority of
employees being Japanese I mean forget
being able to talk with the average
employee how is Howard supposed to
communicate with this executive team who
were almost all Japanese of course they
could communicate in English but I think
you can see why this isn't exactly an
ideal setup and I don't think you'd be
surprised to hear that Sony stock would
fall 75% during Howard's tenure likely
the only notable thing that Howard
accomplished during his tenure was
invest in Spotify which to his credit
did make Sony nearly a billion dollars
but aside from this Howard was more or
less just a dud but while Howard
definitely didn't make things any better
at Sony it wasn't all his fault as
Sony's original Secret Sauce wouldn't
have played out all that well in the
first place as we mentioned Sony had
built their entire company and brand
around the idea of making great reliable
products which is exactly what people
were looking for in the ' 80s and '90s
but moving into the 2000s consumer
demand very much shifted from wanting
great products to wanting great
experiences this seems like a novel
difference but it's not people became
less concerned about the spec sheet and
the price they were more concerned about
how the product made them feel and how
it fit into their lives this is exactly
what Apple capitalized on to great
success so even if Sony did stick to
their roots and didn't get distracted by
other businesses and an American CEO it
probably wouldn't have played out any
better anyway after all this is
basically what they tried doing with the
smartphone industry and that clearly
didn't work out but truth to be told
it's not all Sony's fault
[Music]
either Sony was very much subject to the
headwinds of tech obsolescence much of
what Sony was and is known for people
just don't buy anymore take cameras for
example back in the day everyone one
used to have a home camera but with the
rise of smartphones there's literally no
reason for a dedicated camera unless
you're extremely passionate about
photography and film or it's your job
the same thing can be said about MP3
players as well no one has a dedicated
device to listen to music nowadays they
just use their phones so even if Sony
stayed relevant after the iPod came out
they would have just gotten crushed by
the iPhone anyway it's a similar story
with home entertainment as well people
no longer use Blu-ray players or CDs at
all they just use a streaming service
and a TV and even that's on the decline
and speaking of TVs these are still
extremely popular but they're also
extremely unviable as a business the TV
industry has very much become a race to
the bottom in fact TV prices have been
regularly dropping 15 to 20% in price
every year for the past 20 years at this
point for Samsung and LG TVs are just a
way to maintain brand presence and
dominance not a way to make make profit
this strategy works for them because
they have plenty of other Industries to
rely on the same however cannot be said
about Sony the bottom line for Sony is
that most of the key Industries have
either become completely obsolete or
insanely commoditized both of which are
terrible for business this is why Sony
was losing billions every year and
heading towards an ugly end for much of
the 2010s but things did eventually turn
around right so what happened well I
wish I could say that Sony finally
figured out a new winning strategy and
that they're making the comeback of the
century but that's not really what
happened all that happened was that Sony
basically got their act together in 2012
they put a Sony veteran in charge of
Karai and he basically just salvaged the
remaining parts of Sony he shut down
their unprofitable sectors he reduced
the workforce from 170,000 to just over
100,000 and he spun off their key
sectors into their own businesses so
essentially he separated out the
businesses that were still salvageable
made them independent of the bloated
Giant and cut everything else this has
allowed Sony to recover to profitability
and recover much of their stock losses
but make no mistake Sony is still just a
shell of their former selves in fact
their biggest Revenue driver after the
PS5 is not even an electronic division
it's actually their background Financial
Services Division so the Glory Days of
Sony are still very much behind us which
is quite a shame given how great their
products really are the Silver Lining
however is that while Sony isn't making
a massive Electronics comeback they have
figured out a way to achieve
profitability with what they still have
and that right there is a lot better
than many of their Japanese peers
speaking of Japanese peers Panasonic
also isn't doing all that great check
out this video to learn more but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next
one